all right everybody I want to give  thanks endlessly tonight this is the  happiest moment August in my life and I  owe it to all here in this room number  one  the reason we won this campaign if  there's just one reason and that's  because dollars do not owe you  Thanks American values and virtues right  again animation from  his power belongs to the people serving  as the seventh District Congressman and  then having the privilege to be majority  leader has been one of the highest  honors of my life and you know when I  set out to do and what the agenda that i  have always said we're about is we want  to create a Virginia in America that  works for everybody and we need to focus  our efforts as conservatives as  Republicans on putting forth our  conservative solutions so that they can  help solve the problems for so many  working middle-class families it's  disappointing sure but I believe in this  country I believe there's opportunity  around the next corner for all of us